[Música]
bienvenidos a 5 minutos con hoy
hablaremos sobre el segundo juicio
político contra el ex presidente de
estadounidense donald trump que se lleva
a cabo en el senado de ese país con una
votación de 56 votos a favor de los
cuales seis fueron republicanos y 44 en
contra los senadores aprobaron la
constitucionalidad del proceso por ello
y nos acompaña a michael shifter
presidente del inter-american dialogue
señor shifter gracias por estar aquí con
nosotros en france 24 le pregunto cuál
es el balance que se puede hacer del
primer día del juicio político y cómo
está el panorama para los demócratas y
también para el expresidente trump
bueno yo creo que hay un consenso que
ayer no fue un buen día para presidente
de trump y su caso y que los demócratas
de la cámara fueron el senado y
presentar un caso muy contundente muy
fuerte muy dramático con un vídeo y
argumentos muy sólidos y entonces yo
creo que ahora pasamos a un poco el
juicio y tratando hacer el caso
pero aunque ganó ganó 6 votos
republicanos
para ir al juicio tiene que tener para
para hacer la condición del presente
trans necesita en el 2017 republicanos y
entonces el balance es que los
demócratas le fue bien con la
presentación republicana tener una línea
defensiva muy pobre sin embargo creo que
poca gente cree que va a cambiar el
resultado y que el final
no va a lograr alcanzar los 17 votos
senador republicanos que necesitan
para hacer el juicio final ahora porque
no alcanzarían entonces esos esos 17
votos de los republicanos
buenos republicanos argumentaron 444
sostienen que esto no es un proceso
constitucional y que también dos
argumentos uno es que no es
constitucional y el segundo es que él
tiene
eso es una cuestión de la primera
enmienda de libertad de expresión y que
realmente se puede interpretar sus
palabras no directamente como incitar la
insurrección
directamente entonces yo creo que por
esos dos esos son argumentos más bien de
proceso lo que nadie cuestiona que fue
una cosa terrible y condena el
insurrección el asalto la muerte de
policías y todos los demás pero es una
que es un argumento de proceso pero en
el fondo el problema es que esos
senadores cual tienen miedo del de
editar y en la base del partido que
sigue apoya a pesar de todo aunque creo
que parecen increíbles sigue apoyando
trump señor chips de ver cuáles
estrategia demócrata y los argumentos
para estos días de debate además ellos
tienen la presidencia y la mayoría en
ambas cámaras
claro no yo creo que el argumento es que
tan bueno ayer un poco tenía 11
elementos iniciales del argumento que
esto es algo que ha sido sí sí
un poco volver a los fundadores de la
del país diciendo que es exactamente lo
que ellos tenían los fundadores de tener
a alguien como un que me voy o que
alguien que no aceptará brotados
relaciones y por eso está existe ese
instrumento ese mecanismo de en pixar
mente destrucción en la construcción
entonces no se puede aplicarlo en este
caso que acaso se puede apreciar lo que
ese es el caso peor imaginable eso va a
ser un poco el argumento del de los
demócratas en estos días muy rápidamente
ya para terminar en 30 segundos cómo
afecta esto a la imagen del presidente
del ex presidente de una trump
yo creo es un golpe es un golpe pero si
uno mira en las cuestas él sigue con 38
39 por ciento de apoyo y muy alto en el
partido demócrata
entonces al final balance es que lo
debilita un poco pero todo el día
mantiene su núcleo de apoyo en el
partido republicano señor sister gracias
por estar aquí con nosotros en fresas y
cuatro gracias por su tiempo por
supuesto un gusto haber conversado con
usted
hasta aquí 5 minutos con continúan con
nosotros para más noticias en france 24
[Música]